[موسيقى]
هذه مبادره فرديه من الوالد الله يحفظه هو
اللي بلش فيها اعرف
رتب المكان هذا الاستقبال الجماهير كاس
العالم ضيوف قطر مثل ما قال سمو الامير
هذا كاس العرب
عرفت فادي عادات وتقاليد العرب وهذا
عاداتكم تقاليدنا هذه الاشياء اللي احنا
رفينا عليها مثل ما تشوف انت الحمد اللهم
لك الحمد يعني عندنا ناس يجونا من كل مكان
اللهم لك الحمد احنا من ناحيتنا نورهم
فكره العرب نوريهم العادات والثقافات اللي
احنا نبي نوريها الغرب
[تصفيق]
سبايدر مان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تروح ان هذا تبع الستوت فاحنا نقول لهم ان
هذا لا هذا مكان لنا احنا احنا مش خاصين
في الستوكه عرفت هم من ظاهرين من هالصوره
واحنا هنوريهم كلنا ونوريهم لك العربي
ياكل لك طري الشاي والقهوه والكرك عرفت
ونفس الوقت تعلمهم الثقافاتنا تعلمهم
عاداتنا نعلمهم كيف التاريخ
[موسيقى]
تيتو